[Music]
[Applause]
so
we bring in sean salisbury sean who uh
is the morning host of the sean
salisbury show sports talk 790 in
houston former nfl quarterback
how big did this get in houston there
sean well first off dan was i not in
that playoff
let me win let me see let me
see i'm what 30 less than brady you know
you never won a playoff game
i bit it uh as a starter no the cup
i won the cup the grey cup the great cup
there you go i've been in playoff games
but
i didn't win one as a starter i got us
there but i didn't win one
let's just put it that way brady hasn't
ever won a great cup
you know what that that's a one heck of
a point
yeah so who's better me or brady that's
what you gotta ask you are
better in canada than brady is
yeah i've got i've got far more in
north of the border than brady does dan
uh you asked me about watson first of
all my head's going to explode over this
okay in a houston season when there
wasn't much going on in any of the
sports
we've got harden wants out the astros
had to go through what they went through
uh and self-inflicted and now the best
the second
best building franchise player in this
league
we're talking about being unhappy now
when cal mcnair promised him
that he'd at least have some input i get
his frustration if you're gonna say
something
live by it if not then don't talk to the
quarterback just let him do his thing
deshawn's not getting traded golf got
two ones two twos and two threes daniel
this is herschel walker hall because if
i took desean watson and stuck him in
kansas city and i i think mahomes is the
best in the league
i'm talking about building franchise for
the next seven to ten years
that the kansas city chiefs would still
be the number one seed in 14 and two or
thirteen three if watson was there yeah
if mahomes was in houston the texans
would still be four and 12.
so i'm just telling you that the
distance between
one and two is closer than the distance
between the second and third
best franchise builder in this league
you cannot trade deshaun watson i know
he's
he should be frustrated the ownership is
dysfunctional
he eric the enemy should get an
interview um
but you can't trade him because unless
you want to give me 11 players or
three ones two twos a starter and
another starter
i'm not even answering your damn phone
call yeah but if watson wants out
then would you and well dan he's under
contract
for what five years he's a 40 million
dollar a year player
with his dna and his character okay
let's say it's
august and they haven't traded him let's
just for fun say that
you think he's not showing name me a
quarterback who's in his mid-20s
in the history of this game the number
one we've even thought about trading
as an elite franchise quarterback or
who's held out of camp
for when you're making that money now
you have to find me one it's not it's
not going to happen but what's
management do to appease him sean
um how about just simply call him up
we'll give you input and oh by the way
we'll interview eric the enemy
it doesn't cost that much to interview a
guy who by all standards is not only
prepared
is ringing endorsements from andy from
pat mahomes
and from deshawn watson and around lake
other
people are interviewing uh eric bienemy
what's it take dan put him on a
corporate plane or get on zoom and find
out what you need to know for two hours
i don't think the gm nick casario has
anything to do with desean's frustration
i think it's the dysfunction of the
constant one thing do another
desean should be frustrated would it be
they paid him so he got paid
put some players around him which is
going to be nick casario's job but dan
number
just bring in a guy at least interview
the guy you don't have to let deshawn
hire the guy but deshawn
should have some input shouldn't he no
all your great but should have some
input
i don't think ben roethlisberger has
input i don't think drew brees has input
brady
didn't have him okay if they were going
to trade michael thomas
you don't think that sean payton would
have the respect
or if they were going to trade dk
metcalf in in seattle
you don't i didn't say make the decision
you don't think at least a text message
saying we're considering doing this what
do you think
do you dan i'll tell you this i'll tell
you this and dishonest to god truth
when i was in san diego and i'm no
player there's about eight of us did our
general manager in san diego when bobby
ross
was on his way out called us in to ask
what we thought about the
a possible new replacement a guys who'd
been in the league a while
and i now listen i wasn't exactly your
starter for 10 years
called us in and wanted and bobby
beathard and
we didn't make the decision he just
wanted some input for guys that were
there
because he loved bobby ross and we did
so input so why wouldn't you and if
you're not given input i don't believe
in letting them make a decision brady
manning watson wilson but i do why
wouldn't i have lebron james at least
give me some insight
why wouldn't i let desean watson give me
insight i just signed him for
200 or 175 million bucks and then go
make your decision
and what does it cost to interview a guy
to appease
the guy who quite frankly is a top three
player at his position in this league
i wouldn't have given given him that hey
we're going to consult with you
the promise initially amen yes exactly
but if you give it to him
then you can't go well we're going to
let you
be consulted on certain things but not
this
then i have a problem with that amen one
and i said it out earlier today i said
listen if you're the one just don't say
anything
be the owner let the gm dan i've been in
teams
that i'll bet you there's players across
this league that have never shaken hands
with the owner of their franchise
now meaning you know the owners kind of
sometimes you don't even see them in the
building for
months or two years so if you're going
to go to your franchise player and
promise him live up to the promise
because here's a problem when you lie to
people or you
go back on promises like this committee
like the corn fairy
like promising your quarterback when it
happens once you say okay
happens twice you wonder happens three
times it's a trend
okay everybody makes mistakes so this
has become a trend with the dysfunction
that's cal mcnair in the texans if
you're a head coach now
and you're saying okay i got the
chargers and herbert i got a great
player in watson
but the franchise dysfunction
why would i go there to be a part of
this and it ain't going anywhere right
now and cal mcnair's created this with
desean watson
we don't need number four unhappy but i
agree with you i would have never
tried to consult but if a little input
doesn't hurt anybody doesn't mean you
have to make
the decision desean wants just appease
him after you promised him
by at least giving him a 10 minute
talking to
well i had mike florio on and he had the
initial report
and he said you know probably the reason
why they didn't interview be enemy is
they didn't want to interview him and
then not hire him as opposed to
we're just not interviewing him whatever
the logic is on that
right that's what florio had to say
we're talking to sean salisbury morning
host of the sean salisbury show
sports talk 790 in houston the team
most likely to be upset this weekend is
uh the team that i
listen the defense in indianapolis
can play against anybody the problem i'm
concerned about i don't think you're
going to get an upset this weekend dan
maybe the rams seahawks game maybe
that's not much of an upset right
exactly so you see you may get an upset
there point spread wise
but listen you got a veteran quarterback
my concern about the indianapolis colts
is can
if it's inclement weather and the wind's
blowing and you take him off his mark
and he's not in rhythm thrown on time
i don't think phillip rivers can keep it
up but if you let him get the ball out
of his hand and they run it like they
did last week and keep josh allen
from explosion you can move the ball on
buffalo's defense a little bit i still
don't think it's going to happen
everything would have to go perfect
offensively for the colts i think
buffalo is a real threat to kansas city
um and here's what's ironic about the
saints game
is we always say the saints often saints
off in saints offense if the saints are
getting to february
i believe it's because of defense now on
that one dan is the key is
don't let drew brees get all that rhythm
underneath make him push the ball down
the field
and i am a bit concerned because of the
inconsistency i picked tampa to go to
the super bowl in august i'm not getting
off that
although i'd take green bay now is that
if you're the washington football team
and you can get inside pressure we've
seen some really great games and
he's playing well now from tom and the
bait and the buccaneers
but dan they've also had some clunkers
that are so ugly
that if you can hit them early and force
a few short field turnovers
if this game's in the low 20s or teens
the washington football team is going to
win
if this game creeps into the mid-20s or
upper 20s then
and i expect it to then tampa is going
to win the game so i probably the rams
game but i think the favorites in these
and i don't usually like favorites all
the way across the board i think it's
going to be a favorite weekend and i
think the favorites are usually going to
walk away with this one you know it may
sound strange but if kevin stefanski was
going to be able to coach in this game i
would lean towards the browns
yeah i agree because i i don't know what
i have in pittsburgh
ben has not played well in the last
month and a half
uh they got receivers who dropped passes
they're not formidable in the running
game the defense is not as formidable as
it once was and it feels like the browns
at least know who they are they may not
be great
but they know who they are and that's
part of the battle in the nfl
they got their identity finally dan
after a lot of years and you know what
you make that's probably the best one
here's why and you mentioned
pittsburgh's
really not making those big chunk play
now they did in the second half
um you know in their in their last game
of the the game 15.
but you know what dana and i i actually
didn't even look at cleveland as the
underdog so you're probably right i
i actually think cleveland can beat
pittsburgh i do because if you don't
you know with the lack of with some
injuries on the defensive side and i
understand stefanski not being there
van pelt's got a heavy job ahead of him
but you know how that is dan sometimes
it's like well let's give kevin
next week so let's reach deep inside now
not that should be the reason
but if you run the ball and control it
and hit ben i'm with you and i should
have looked at that as probably the
number one
but i didn't because i i'm not so sure i
don't think that cleveland right now
that they're better than pittsburgh i do
mayfield got to play and be accurate
but the way they run the football and
they get after ben and
and prevent that big play i don't
disagree with you one bit i actually
think pittsburgh if i had
if i had to bet money on this game i'm
not so sure i wouldn't take cleveland
myself so in the point spread side it's
an upset without stefanski
i think they're going to rise i think
this is going to be a really really
really
late fourth quarter football game uh
i've had people on recently
and i've asked them the following
question i'll give you trevor lawrence
or justin herbert everybody has said
justin herbert
i've talked to a couple people that i
said i asked the question dan people
that are either in the know or study
this stuff that we do and i said
it of all the current players in the
league and the draft that's coming out
in 2021
would trevor lawrence where would he fit
in in building a franchise and not one
of them still taking him outside the top
five
of the guys i've talked to now for me i
understand herbert these same guys that
are saying that now were probably
eight months ago or around drought are
saying
i don't know because we all were let's
face facts we we missed on
because he didn't buy in it's kind of
like people missed on josh allen
uh he's inaccurate yeah he's complete
around 70 and as an mvp candidate
i guess today i would but if you told me
right now dan
you got to build a franchise and i love
herbert
but if you i think lawrence is different
i would take trevor lawrence over
herbert it's easy to say herbert now
because we've seen the result
yeah but i would i would still have to
take lawrence because i think
when all is said and done that ceiling i
think he can break a bigger hole in the
ceiling than herbert but i'm going to
tell you
this is one of the great misses by a lot
of us i didn't think herbert would be
this good
this fast and that's the number one job
right now dan
because the personnel around herbert
watson makes it an
attractive job the dysfunction makes it
an inter an unattractive job but
the chargers job's the number one job
out there right now because of that
his brilliance early in his career urban
meyer is interviewing with jacksonville
why would i would admire take this job
well
there's i got there's a kid in clemson
who's pretty good urban's not stupid dad
you and i both know that
he wouldn't take the job if if uh if
gardner-menchie was the quarterback and
they weren't getting and i don't mean
this disrespect to menchie but
he's got that to build on um and now i
got about 10 million reasons why i
wouldn't let him out of the building but
let's say they had the number two pick
not the number one pick sean does urban
meyer take that job
i think urban's ego and i mean this
affectionately would think that he could
make whoever
it is zach wilson or justin fields that
he that he could turn them into
that guy i i believe he thinks that now
i know people in college and nfl
but dan jacksonville's got to do
something different
and i wouldn't let him outside the
building today he's proven leadership
he's won
everywhere but the nfl so until he
proves to me he can't
i i'm telling you he's the number one
coaching candidate on the planet
that's not coaching what college nfl
high school
the cfl i don't care if you're
jacksonville plus people will go to the
stands
you've got trevor lawrence i i wouldn't
let him out of the building i'd pay him
six seven years and i'd give him 10
million bucks and say
let's see we got we need a big hit
and urban meyer's the biggest hit on the
coaching circuit right now i just don't
think he'll last
i don't think he'll last more than four
four years five years will that be
enough dan to get them back in the hunt
well it's going to take two years you
would think right
right at least you know two years
because you know the colts are good
like if you just look at the uh the afc
south tennessee is good
so you're competing in your own division
you you're not even the texans
right now right right so i think just
he's never lost
and and you know what that is like guys
who come out of college and they're like
i lost one or two games and all of a
sudden you lose 14 or 15. i talked to
troy aikman about it he was like
man i i took it home with me every day
it was like something you wear i
couldn't get
get rid of it well think about this dan
and i talked to dick vermeel about that
same thing he said
i should have enjoyed the wins as much
as i suffered from the losses right
but they don't and urban right you lose
four games at a c
in a season and urban's like i lost four
games in 14 years dude
when i was at bowling green so dan well
let me ask you this
let's say sc job came open would urban
have them or texas if you were to take
it instead of sarc
would they be in the national title uh
final four in two years
texas no southern cal
no i'm going to say because alabama and
clemson and ohio state have such a head
start on
everybody and jacksonville if
jacksonville
gets if myers signs with them and
lawrence is the call
and urban stays around six years will
they win the division
more than once while he's there
i don't think he'll stay six years but
i would say that they would win i could
see them winning a division i'm gonna
i i could i'm not i'm not letting him
out of the building but i'm with you
the if it's an eight-year contract he
ain't stay at all eight years
book sean salisbury for six years down
the road the next time we'll have him on
will be six years and then we'll bring
up urban meyer in jacksonville
hey guess what you're the only guys that
want to book me ahead of time
have a good weekend thank you sean as
always happy new year dan appreciate you
buddy
sean salsberry a morning host of the
sean salisbury show
and sports talk 790 in houston